this was a truly horrific incident and a
tragic loss of life
the jury to the inquest into these
deaths returned their findings of
unlawful killings yesterday afternoon
and our thoughts and prayers once again
go out to the families and friends of
the victims
and indeed to the whole community in
Kiam
I would like to pay a particular Tribute
to The Honorable member for Plymouth
Sutton and devonport for his tireless
campaigning on behalf of the Kim
community and the families since this
tragedy took place
it is anticipated that the coroner will
be issuing a prevention of future death
reports very very shortly in which
further recommendations are likely to be
made
if as expected the home office receives
such a report
um we will be responding to that along
with the recommendations made by the
independent office of police conduct who
were conducted an investigation to these
shootings and a separate inquiry by the
Scottish Affairs committee substantively
within 60 days of receiving that
prevention of future deaths report
Madam Deputy speaker the government
keeps Firearms licensing under review to
safeguard against abuse and prevent risk
to Public Safety
in the immediate aftermath of these
shootings in Plymouth the then Home
Secretary asked all police forces to
urgently review their firearms licensing
practices
the review found that collectively a
total of
6434 firearms and shotgun licenses were
surrendered seized revoked or refused
over the previous 12-month period across
England Wales and Scotland of these a
total of 908 were subsequently returned
or issued reissued following further
checks or appeals decided by the courts
as a result of the review of returned
licenses in eight cases the original
decision was overturned and the licenses
have been re-surrendered or revoked I
hope these findings provide reassurance
that the police have put in place
robust processes for issuing and
reviewing firearms and shotgun licenses
I mean there is any complacency Madam
Deputy speaker following these awful
events
subsequently there were strengthened
controls issued through statutory
guidance in October 2021 a few months
after this awful incident to make sure
the police must ensure people are
medically fit to receive a license and
that full medical checks have been
undertaken something which did not
happen of course in this case a new
digital marker system to flag Firearms
owners to GPS is also currently being
introduced
the statutory guidance draws on previous
lessons learned and will ensure better
consistency across police and Firearms
licensing departments it will mean that
no one or it means already that no one
will be given a firearms license unless
their doctor has expressly confirmed to
the police whether or not they have any
relevant medical conditions including in
relation to their mental health the
statutory guidance makes it clear that
police can undertake a wide range of
checks now to assess a person's
suitability depending on the individual
case including social media checks
Financial checks interviews background
checks with relatives or Associates and
checks relating to domestic violence or
with public protection units
the College of policing has also
refreshed its authorized professional
practice on Firearms licensing a
consultation was launched about a month
ago on the 12th of January it will
conclude on the 10th of March and I
would encourage members to respond to
that consultation
inspectorate of constabury Fire and
Rescue Services has also announced it
will be undertaking a thematic review of
all forces Arrangements in respect to
Firearms Licensing in the year 24 25.
now in relation to Devon and Cornwall
they have assured the iopc that changes
have been made following the iopc's
recent recommendations but depending on
what the coroner might recommend shortly
I am currently minded to ask the
inspectorate to go and look specifically
at the arrangements that Devon and
Cornwall have in place to Firearms
licensing to confirm their suitability
the home office is also currently taking
forward a review of fees that can be
charged for firearms licenses or
certificates by police forces and we
expect to be Consulting later this year
that's to make sure that forces have
enough resources
um to conduct these very important
checks
Madame Deputy speaker we must ensure our
controls on Firearms are as robust as
possible and learn the lessons from the
tragic deaths
um in Kiam and also in Scotland and we
therefore await the coroners anticipated
report
um into the prevention of future deaths
with Keen interest and as I have said we
will respond to the expected Coroner's
report on preventing future deaths and
the recent report by the Scottish
Affairs committee following the
shootings in sky and the iopc report
within 60 days of receiving the last of
those three reports which is going to be
the coroner's report and we will respond
substantively to the recommendations in
all three reports
I commit today that any further changes
needed to protect the public will be
made and I commend this statement to the
house
Shadow Minister Sarah Jones
thank you madam Deputy speaker and I
thank the minister for advanced site of
his statement
today we mourn Sophie Martin who was
only three Lee Martin Stephen Washington
Kate Shepard and Maxine Davidson
I also want to pay tribute to my
honorable friend for Plymouth Sutton and
devonport for his work
I know that he has been affected very
deeply as has his community
the jurors conclusions are searing the
IOP PC report is damning catastrophic
failure at Devon and Cornwall police in
the individual decisions that were taken
in the appalling lack of supervision
training and oversight and in the rules
themselves
there is no automatic right to bear arms
in this country
there is no right to be given the
benefit of the doubt
after dunblane Firearms units were to be
given as much training and guidance as
possible and yet Devon and Cornwall
police had no formal training for two
decades
the Firearms licensing supervisor told
the court he'd done a two-day training
course in 1998 but nothing else until
2020.
how could it possibly be that the person
in charge of deciding whether someone
was safe with a gun hasn't even been
trained on how to use the risk manual
this casual approach to risk was
dangerous and proved to be fatally
flawed
the last hmic inspection on Firearms was
eight years ago in 2015. I'm glad that
the minister has told us today that the
next one will be completed in 24 25 but
I do ask why we need to wait a year and
whether this can be brought forward
the 2015 inspection raised concerns that
police force practice on licensing was
inconsistent
but the public consultation on statutory
guidance only started in 2019.
the government failed to respond to the
consultation
Luke Davidson used his licensing weapon
to kill five people in 2021.
Madam Deputy speaker Devin and Cornwall
now rejects six percent of gun
applications since the Kim shooting but
the national average across England is
only 3 percent the is frankly terrifying
to think that other pump action shotguns
could be in the wrong hands
Jake Davidson's childhood and teenage
history should have triggered far more
questions and expert advice
there was information about him that was
never revealed
the mental health marker is finally
being introduced but it is within the
statutory guidance not a legal Duty and
experts have raised concerns about the
new system
is the minister aware of those concerns
and is he satisfied with the new markers
what are the government's plans to make
sure there is a proactive approach to
risk management on Firearms licensing
how will the minister ensure that
statutory guidance is followed by police
forces and that forces are held to
account for it
Madam Deputy speaker Jake Davidson was
an incel the online radical
radicalization of young men has been
overlooked for far too long
in the last year there were 77 referrals
to prevent for insil on 154 referrals
for potentially planning or thinking
about a school massacre
if people are referred to prevent can
the minister explain if there is a flag
on prevent systems to notify the police
if they have a gun license
I would like to hear from the minister
what action his government is taking to
tackle misogynist extremism because his
government watering down the Online
safety bill means misogynists and inside
gangs will continue to proliferate
online
the current counter-extremism strategy
is eight years out of date can the
minister tell us when the government
will update the strategy
can the minister tell the house why he
does not accept the iopc's
recommendations in full I understand
he's waiting 60 days for other pieces of
work to be concluded but I think he
could accept the irpc's very sensible
recommendations in full today
the new Chief Constable of Devon and
Cornwall police has called for
legislation on Firearms licensing does
the minister agree
we are alert to concerns about pump
action shotguns in homes what is the
home office view on that
labor in government will initiate a
review of gun Licensing Laws we must
learn the lessons so that what happened
in kiem can never happen again nothing
else will do
minister
thank you madam depth speak and I um
thank the shadow Minister for her her
comments and her questions I'll try and
answer as many as I uh I can here but
I'm sure we'll discuss this again uh in
the future on the question of the HMI
cfrs thematic inspection
um that is programmed as I set out but I
but the point I made about Devon and
Cornwall specifically is something
subject to the coroner's recommendations
and that I will be asking them to do a
lot sooner essentially um if they're
willing to do it uh immediately to make
sure that the assurances they've given
to the iopc the Devon and Cornwall have
implemented already all of the
recommendations uh you know have indeed
been done I think that is something that
does need to happen
um essentially straight away and subject
to the coroner's report uh what that may
have to say about it um I'll be asked
I'll be writing to HMI cfrs on that
basis
um very very shortly
um in relation to concerns about the the
new markers being placed on files
ensuring there is a proactive approach
to risk management and indeed the need
for legislation in this area and those
are all topics that I can commit will be
addressed in our response to these three
reports I think it's important to
respond to all three together rather
than piecemeal and I don't think 60 days
is too long to wait uh for that I've
been very clear
um with um colleagues that that is what
we need to do respond substantively
within 60 days of that Coroner's report
which is itself expected very very
shortly indeed I completely agree with
the shadow Minister's point that people
with Davidson's background should not
receive Firearms licenses indeed under
the rules in place at the time he should
not have received a firearms license and
the iopc in their recent report
identified I think two or three
um individuals within the Devon and
Cornwall Force who they considered the
iopc considered guilty of misconduct by
authorizing wrongly authorizing the
issue of that license which Davison as I
say should never have received even
under the regulations as they stood both
in 2018 and in uh 2020.
um in relation to the question about
radicalization
um I think the if someone has been
referred into prevent and there's any
substantive evidence of radicalization
um it is reasonable that that should be
uh known to the police in making
decisions about Firearms licenses
um and I will undertake to look to
confirm um that that is the case and if
it's not the case to see what steps can
be taken to make sure and there is a
link between the prevent database and
checks performed by
um Firearms
um officers
um Madam speaker um there's a lot of
material to cover I think the response
the government substantive response to
government's going to bring forward
um in approximately two months time I
think we'll answer
um I think all of the questions
um and more and no doubt there'll be a
statement to the house on the occasion
of presenting that
oh my name is thank you uh can I welcome
The Minister's suggestion that the
bniopc investigation of Devon cornwall's
operation of firearms regulations I
think I'm right in saying they are the
largest they have the largest number of
licenses within their territory so if
they're not getting it right
um then we need some reassurance that
they they are and can I also welcome the
fact that he underlined that even under
the existing regulations
um this particular person should not
have received his Firearms back and it
was a misapplication if you like of
those regulations that resulted in the
situation that we find ourselves in
having said that I'm sure the minister
would accept and and he will have had
the same experience that I did that
Firearms legislation is in fact an
accretion of policies over the years and
has become a bit of a Thicket for us all
to navigate and that we should have a
look at a some kind of review overall
but in particular the critical role that
the medical profession will now play in
general Community safety and what more
does the minister think we can do to
impress upon that profession profession
the duty they have not just to the
community more widely but to the The
Wider body of those who do shoot and do
operate firearms for work purposes or
indeed Leisure purposes and not to stand
in the way of that process we often
found Medics who would refuse to
certificate issue certification for
people who would charge excessive fees
for certification therefore not fully
participating in the system given that
this case proves The crucial nature of
their assessment to all of our safety
what more does the Miss I think we can
do to impress that upon the medical
profession
Minister well I thank the my honorable
friend um for his question I know when
he was uh in this role he met with the
uh the families of the victims I
completely agree with his points about
the medical profession I would Echo his
call for the medical profession to be
proactive when they're approached by the
police in relation to Firearms licenses
uh to make uh full uh disclosures
um as uh in consultation of course with
their uh with their patients and also
where they see a flag that is of concern
to them to proactively contact the
police as this tragic case shows
um there can be devastating consequences
for the public where somebody that
should not have a gun has one and I
think there is a an ethical Duty and a
moral duty on the medical profession
which they owe to society as a whole as
well as to their patient as an
individual and I would strongly urge
um GPS not the medical professions
professionals to keep that wider moral
duty firmly in mind and to cooperate
with the police on these issues
uh Luke Paulo
your mom Deputy speaker I
thought and our community is angry we're
still hurting and grieving for those
that we lost
but also fitting for those who are shot
and survived
confidence in Devon and Cornwall police
has been badly shaken by the catalog of
catastrophic failures that led up to
this tragedy we've been failed locally
by our police but nationally we're also
being failed by gun laws that need to be
brought up to date the families of the
victims and those who survived want to
see changes a review of gun laws to
bring them up to date to make them 21st
century an urgent review of gun
licensing which has failed us so badly
not just in Devon and Cornwall but for
every other gun license licensing
Authority everywhere else in the country
a ban on keeping pump action weapons in
someone's home with exceptions for
farmers and pest controllers and a
national in-cell strategy to deal with
this growing toxic problem
training for firearms officers
Nationwide and importantly full cost
recovery so the police have the
resources to process applications
properly
so I can ask the minister if he'll agree
to meet with me and the families so he
they can impress upon him the strength
of their loss but also the strength of
the determination in Plymouth to make
sure that there will be comprehensive
changes to our gun laws to make sure
that no other community anywhere in the
country will have to go through what we
have in Plymouth
Minister well a thankful member for his
question and I will of course meet with
the uh the families of the victims
annual honorable member as I think my
predecessor has done to listen to their
concerns directly and make sure that
their voice is is heard in government
um he raised a number of points in his
question
um as I said to the shadow Minister the
response we intend to produce very
shortly
um should address uh those points that
he outlined
um clearly the family may have other
points they would like to add to those
and that we can take into account so I'd
suggest we have that meeting in the next
month or so so that they've used can
feed into the comprehensive response
that I've described on the specific
question of fees that he mentioned to
ensure that there is full cost recovery
and police forces get them the money
that it costs them to run these
licensing Arrangements that is something
we do intend to consult on
um over the uh the summer or Early
Autumn to make sure that happens as
quickly as possible so I can make that
commitment now
to Gary's treatment very much speaker
can I make my own Tribute to The
Honorable member for Plymouth Sutton and
devonport who has done an outstanding
work on this issue since this appalling
event in 2021 can I thank the minister
for a statement and for the support the
home office has given actually to the
people of Plymouth after in the
aftermath of this tragedy and can I
welcome the review that he's talked
about today but can I ask him not to
close his mind to a thorough review of
the law in relation to firearms because
I think I take the point that it's it's
quite ancient some of it and it needs to
be brought together and looked at in the
light of Internet influences as well as
medical conditions but can I finally I
don't speak and thank you for being kind
to me can I can I say that um has the
minister seen in relation to wider
cultural issues through excellent report
produced by the commission
of
um violence against women and girls by
the Plymouth by the Plymouth commission
which tries to tackle from the bottom up
some of these cultural issues has he
seen it and can he commend the Plymouth
city council for continue to take that
work forward
thank you madam speaker well look I'd
like to Echo my um runnable friends uh
tribute to the families uh of the
victims who have shown I think
extraordinary bravery in the way they've
handled this situation and advocated for
change what have been for them obviously
very difficult
um circumstances
um yes we will obviously consider
recommendations for any changes to the
law that may follow uh from these three
reports that we're going to be
um considering on the question about
vorg and yes I am aware of excellent
work led by Plymouth City councilor
councilor Rebecca Smith uh on a Vogue
strategy designed to combat these kind
of issues
um I know my honorable friend the member
for
um louth and horncastle
um when she was safeguarding Minister
um visited Plymouth together with
Rebecca Smith
um to to discuss her um excellent report
and I would actually commend the
approach that councilor Smith has
developed in Plymouth to other local
authorities around the country
they'll address some oil thank you madam
Deputy speaker and my thoughts of course
are with the families and the victims
and
um the Sterling work of course that my
honorable friend has done on this I
wrote to his predecessor in 2020
asking for
um asking for medical markers to be put
on the records for there to be a review
of the fees uh that both GPS were
charging but that
um police forces were able to charge and
work then the correspondence back was
that work was being done on it
but clearly work was not done on it
quick enough
and so I think it what is important is
not just the 60 days in which the
minister will respond but some
indication of a timetable of
implementation for some of these changes
and particularly for a statutory footing
for that medical marker because I am
worried without it being statutory and
without it being part of the NHS
contract for GPS to have to report it I
am worried that it will be a weak
enforcement
a minister thank you Melissa I can't
can't speak for my um my predecessor but
what I can say is that a number of steps
have happened to the point about urgency
a number of steps have been taken
already the authorized updated
authorized professional practice
guidance from the College of policing is
out for consultation now it started in
January
um it'll close in March updated
statutory guidance was issued uh in
October 2021 ensuring that there must be
medical checks
um in every single
um case uh on the medical marker point
that he raised uh medical markers um are
as we speak being fully rolled out so
that is that is in hand and on the
question of fees as I said um I can
commit to a consultation
um over the summer or Early Autumn uh on
those fees with the objective in mind of
ensuring uh full-cost recovery in
relation to the response to the
recommendations I think 60 days uh
following the coroners report is a um is
a good timetable for response that will
obviously contain a proposed
implementation timetable people
um but they don't remember and others
and can be assured that I want to get
any changes needed and I'm sure there
will be changes
um implemented as a matter of urgency
for obvious reasons
Celine Saxby Deputy speaker and can I
ask my very honorable friend as he looks
to review their licensing arrangements
for Devon and Cornwall police that it
accurately reflects the vast rural area
that this Force actually covers we've
already heard that it does have a high
level of gun ownership linked to those
remote Farms that do require them for
work but um there is a concern that
actually there's already a backlog in
the renewal system and that the rurality
is not adequately reflected in the
resources that the force receives
Minister okay well thank my friend for
her um question
um obviously Devon and Cornwell is a
large um Geographic
um area I understand that there are now
more resources being deployed by Devon
and Cornwall police into Firearms
licensing uh partly following this awful
incident but partly because there are
quite large backlogs in Devon and
Cornwall specifically
um for firearms licensing so there are
more resources being deployed um for
this purpose and but I would say
notwithstanding the reality of Devon and
Cornwall or indeed many other parts of
the country and we can't obviously have
different or lower standards I know that
wasn't what the honorable lady
um was suggesting we do need to make
sure the standards are high everywhere
across the country in relation to the
resource question more generally and
there's an intention to consult shortly
on the police funding formula and one of
the inputs into that will be reality to
make sure that adequate resources are
given to more rural forces to reflect
the additional costs that they very
often face
should food
Adam Deputy speaker the inquest
concluded that the shootings in Plymouth
resulted from a catastrophic failure
the responsibility lies entirely with
the murderer and I don't want to repeat
his name
but the Firearms licensing department
wasn't given the resources that it it
needed and the the police and crime
commissioner in Devon and Cornwall has
admitted as much and and said I've made
significant funding available to improve
the Devon and Cornwall police's Firearms
licensing department this obviously
since the inquest Madam Deputy speaker
what conversations has the minister had
with the police and crime commissioner
in Devon and Cornwall about these
findings and what additional changes
would he like to see in the oversight of
Devon and Cornwall police
Minister thank you we'll have had
extensive discussions uh both inside the
home office and with policing including
pccs on the question of firearms
um licensing
um as I said in answer to the previous
question extra resources uh inside Devon
Cornwall have been dedicated now
following this awful incident to the
question of firearms licensing and of
course police forces up and down the
country
um will by the end of next month have
record numbers of police
um officers in terms of changes to
practice
um I would like to receive that the
third of those three reports the first
being
um the Scottish Affairs committee report
the second being the iopc report the
third being the anticipated coroners
prevention and future deaths report and
respond to their recommendations in the
round within 60 days as I've committed
already and I would expect there to be a
number of changes proposed and in those
uh responding to those recommendations
applying not just to Devon and Cornwall
but also to policing more widely as I
also said earlier the IP PC have already
made specific recommendations directed
at Devin and Cornwall Devon and Cornwall
police have assured the iopc those
proposed changes have been implemented
and but I am minded to ask hmic to
specifically check up on that shortly
McCrory thank you madam Deputy speaker
um can I pay tribute to the whole
community of Kim and particularly to The
Honorable member for Plymouth Sutton and
devonport for his work on this since it
happened
um there are three Cornish MPS in the
chamber today but I know I speak for all
six of us and actually everybody west of
the time I won he he will know that we
stand shoulder to shoulder with his
community uh throughout this ordeal and
going forward
um it was good to see the chief
Constable of Devon and Cornwall police
although recently appointed wilcare
apologize for the forces failings and to
take accountability for what has
happened and has called for legislation
on this I would Echo what everybody has
said about the medical markers
um and uh for making sure we have the
right balance for legislation but is
there an opportunity to consider a
national unit to standardize licensing
and processing and the decision-making
to help the resource for the local
police forces
I'm going to thank my honorable friend
for her for her question I think
nationally consistent standards are
extremely important we need to make sure
the standards are equally High across
the entire uh country that is part of
the reason why the College of policing
are currently Consulting on updated
authorized professional practice to make
sure all those standards
um are clear and it further changes are
necessary um they will obviously be
introduced I think the other point
that's very important is to make sure
the College of policing
um also introduce essentially
standardized training and that is
obviously uh also in hand it's a point
that the shuttle Minister referred to in
her questions earlier to make sure that
everybody up and down the country has
received um proper training that was
clearly a failing in Devon and Cornwall
we need to make sure that doesn't happen
again anywhere
at Rachel maskell thank you madam Deputy
speaker today will be a difficult day
for the community in kiem and my
thoughts are with them but I'm not
reassured around the the government's
response particularly around mental
health but also for victims of domestic
violence and their former partners I've
got a constituent right now is in who is
in hiding because her former partner has
had his Firearms returned to him so what
reassurance can he give to ensure that
this instant will not be that will be
the last and that my constituent will
also be safe
uh Minister well I think everyone's
constituents including the other ladies
are entitled to feel uh safe um as the
show Minister said Firearms licenses are
not a not a right uh it's important we
think very very carefully before issuing
anyone with such a license and as I said
before uh we will be responding
comprehensively to the recommendations
in these three reports I'm sure that
will include I know that will include uh
consideration of issues to do with
domestic abuse and domestic violence
which are clearly indicators of
substantially
um increased risk and I'd be very happy
to um discuss those recommendations
um with her and indeed her constituent
if she would like as soon as they come
out
so Julian Lewis is it correct as I think
has been reported that in this tragic
case the murderer's mother appealed to
the police to have the returned firearm
removed from him and was ignored if that
is true isn't it also the case that no
change in any licensing system will be
able to compensate for that level of
bungling incompetence
well I'm afraid to say
um very bad decisions
um in fact wrong decisions um were made
in this case and as the former police
Minister Miranda will friend the member
for Northwest Hampshire said under the
guidance in Force at the time
both in I think 2018 when the license
was first granted and two or three years
later when the gun was confiscated and
then returned under the guidance enforce
at the time uh those decisions were
wrongly taken and the iopc has said that
very clearly and they said that there
were two or three
um employees or officers of Devon and
Cornwall police who made uh the wrong
decision at the time so he's right to
say a change of guidance wouldn't have
helped because the wrong decisions were
made under the guidance at a time
however we do need to make sure that the
guidance is robust it's comprehensive
training is comprehensive and is it is
exactly with those purposes in mind that
we're going to be responding to the
three reports uh in 60 days or so